aujourd'hui on amorce un changement de
culture et c'est un trio solide qui en
fera sa mission selon Sylvain
Croteau ça ce ci Québec
perd de la formation à de jeunes
accueilleurs pour revenir implanter sur
le terrain outiller les intervenants
pour vraiment faire en sorte que les
climates soient positifs donc on va
faire la preuve dans ce projet pilote
que le plaisir le bien-être peuvent
cohabiter avec la performance qu'ils
peuvent même favoriser la performance le
projet est dans les cartons depuis
plusieurs années et il arrive à point
nommer on a mal à notre hockey
actuellement bah là il faut il faut en
prendre soin la part d'un citoyen
corporatif comme le Canadien de Montréal
c'est un grand message l'initiative est
saluée alors que le hockey est dans la
tourmente des allégations de viol
collectifs ont éclaboussés ok Canada cet
été et tout récemment c'est l'allée
canadienne d'or qui j'ignore qui a dû
s'expliquer sur la culture des
initiations
sont hésités à faire un pas de l'avant
mais c'est à nous les citoyens à mettre
nos culottes et leur montrer quoi faire
quand faire et de ne plus tolérer
surtout de ne plus fermer les yeux car
le Canada n'est pas le seul pays où des
organisations sont remises en question
mais Jean-Luc brassard et David qu'il
pourra se démarquer par la façon dont
les changements seront gérés si le
Canada en général veut se démarquer sur
la scène internationale c'est pas avec
un nombre extraordinaire de médailles
gagnées au contraire c'est en mettant
des programmes ou les athlètes vont
pouvoir vraiment faire du sport dans les
vrais valeurs du sport celles qu'on
véhicule toujours mais finalement on
respecte pas le défi maintenant
s'assurer que ces programmes fonctionne
le suivi va être d'autant plus important
pour s'assurer que on garde le cap le
mécanisme de suivi va être aussi
important sinon plus important que tout
programme le programme Moi j'embarque
sera lancé dès l'automne qui recevra
d'abord la formation les paramètres
exacts restent encore à être déterminés
ici qui me permettra au Canada Montréal